it is a story we have been following all
day that crash happened off u.s
95 this morning south of boulder city we
do have team coverage tonight
joe mohler and the i-team's vanessa
murphy live tonight with reaction from
the cycling community
as well as safety tips for cyclists but
first let's begin with kristen
drummond who is live at the scene with
more on what exactly happened
kristen
[Music]
denise and brian the deadly crash
happening across the highway from me
here on u.s 95 south at around 9
30 this morning the location is about 15
miles north of
searchlight the southbound lanes were
shut down for
about six hours today troopers say about
10
cyclists were riding south when a white
box truck driving the same direction
went into their lane
now the reason why remains unknown right
now but impairment
is not suspected nhp confirms four men
and
one woman died three others were hurt
including one who was airlifted to umc
trauma
nhp says the cyclists on the ride were
familiar with the route and made this
trip before
a support and gear car also known as a
sag vehicle
also accompanied them until today's
tragedy they
they've never had any problems they
didn't have a safety vehicle with them
what i understand though is the safety
vehicle
ended up in a position where they were
bicyclists both in front of it
at the time of this crash
the driver of the sag car was
hospitalized
and hp says the box truck driver was not
hurt
and cooperated with troopers i'm told
that the cyclists who participated in
the group ride are all
advanced cyclists and this is all part
of a 130 mile
bike birthday ride